first of all creating something that
goes viral is such a crazy feeling
and you've done it a ton i mean you
built the hustle with a bunch of
really viral blog posts like this is
kind of nothing in comparison to the
blog post you guys wrote
and also you're a writer so you kind of
have a process where you sniff out
stuff that you think is going to go
viral whereas for me i'm not really a
writer this is kind of me
just trying to i mean you you you have
the it factor i think that
um i think you can study and how to do
it
i think that you can just be born with
the skill set
um i think you and i are quite similar
in that it's both born
or we we have that natural gift and also
we learn and master the craft right i
think you've tried it a lot more and
therefore your hit
rate i think is is higher i personally i
just think that but um
the question i was going to do i mean
dude you got to 120 000 followers on
twitter in like basically six months
yeah that's true um so i wanted to share
so when i uh so the way this
this came about because i think this is
ultimately more interesting right the
rant is kind of interesting but
the how this happened i think for people
who are listening they'll probably find
it
i think they find interesting um the way
they started was
a pretty high profile vc person called
me one day
i had never met them before they had
said oh you seem interesting on twitter
i'd love to meet so we did a phone call
and then we were talking just about each
other's backgrounds was cool and then
they were like well what do you think of
clubhouse by the way i gotta ask
and um and i think they asked this
because they had looked at investing
they ultimately didn't invest and they
were trying to figure out like
am i gonna kick is this gonna be is this
gonna haunt me you know for the next
five years that i missed this deal or is
this gonna be a good one
and um you know a good pass and i
basically i i just went on this rant on
the phone about this
it just kind of came out of my mouth
just the way i kind of explained it here
and um without the whole like kind of
dramatized
like tv show script but just the reasons
why i think it's gonna
struggle and um and they were like wow
that was great like that was amazing and
i was like [__] i should have wrote that
down that was like
that would have um i feel like that
would have been like
a good like piece of content and so i
went i
kind of like quickly was like i gotta go
and i hung up the phone and
i went to my computer and i just typed
the whole thing out and um
and it turned into like and then i was
like okay whatever i i kind of edited i
took it out i
did your your tip which i took a break
for an hour yeah just
went and did something else came back
and i edited it for about 30 minutes
editing is the magic to everything it
doesn't matter you're talking about a
viral tweet
a good email editing is the magic they
say write drunk edit sober
oh that's a great one i've never heard
that i love that um think you're in
attendance
i used to just edit in the moment like
i'd write i don't know
and that was a mistake the tip you gave
me a while back was
go do other [__] let it simmer in your
head while you do other things don't
even actively think about it
by the time you come back you can make
it twice as good in 20 minutes yeah and
there's actually some science behind it
i i i can't tell you the exact science
off the top of my head but basically
you know how there's like a shower
thought of like not doing it so there's
like science behind like doing something
really hard and then not doing it and
then things hit you
uh there is science behind why that
works and that's kind of what you're
doing
yeah basically like the brain relaxes in
some way and then when it relaxes it's
able to be creative in a new way
and so um okay so then i post it and
then whatever you know
[__] as well so then uh so that was that
was the oh sorry the other part that i
forgot which i think is my new it's
something i've been doing
and i'm curious if you do something like
this before uh
before i write anything now at the top
of every page i have a template and at
the top there's like seven lines that
says
what reaction is this meant to get and i
have seven emotions
it's like lol like this is meant to be
really funny
is it wtf where it's like dude what the
[__] and that's when you're talking
about something that's really unjust
or people are pissed off and you want to
you want to explain hey there's this
really messed up thing that's happening
and people will be like oh my god
um then there's other ones like you know
like aw
aww something really cute awe oh like
like that something is awesome like wow
that is like kind of amazing
wait did i tell you that i do this no i
actually learned this from these other
guys who make viral videos
rubber republic they had a search engine
where you would just search by
one of these emotions and it would pull
up viral videos that had that
that were based on that emotion wow so
the way to go viral is you always want
to start
you start with the emotion that you're
trying to get out of someone um and you
and we already know that certain
emotions get more shares
so for example creating depression or
sadness that doesn't get shares
um creating outrage gets far more and
with small tweaks you can make something
sad outrageous and that's far better
right you know so it's either amazing
it's super funny
it's really really outraging it's um
it's really touching and heartwarming
that's another one um hard to do
and then the one i had for this which is
kind of like a new emotion which was
i wrote finally someone said it
and i actually think that's a that's its
own genre that i didn't even have in my
template
because i was like i think this is going
to go viral but it doesn't match any of
these
i was like i think for some people it's
going to be wtf like dude this guy's a
jerk why is he predicting failure
what an [__] but i thought no it's
going to go viral because if you say
something that a lot of people have been
thinking but they've been afraid to say
or they couldn't put words around it
exactly but they had this hunch
they will share it because they agree
with your opinion
it's the idea of recognizing something
that you feel that you weren't sure if
other people feel but you see it on
paper
so the same example is with location so
when you see
like uh how you know you're a san
francisco bro or
how do i know uh do you know sean perry
like if i said if
i saw an ad that said do you know sean
i'd be like oh wait that's directed just
towards me
right so what the emotion that you just
evoked was like finally i didn't think i
was the only one who thought like
it's a recognizing it's it's a
recognizing something type of
vibe and they're really sharing because
they're like i knew it
i i'm right so they're not saying wow
he's so right they're actually saying
i'm right
read this this proves i'm right which is
like a real subtle thing but i'm so
interested in studying the like
psychology around
why people do what they do why do they
share what they share
because i want to grow an audience and
this is the best way to grow it and
i feel like this i'm this process that
i'm doing i'm so glad you said you do it
too because i thought i was a little
crazy i was like oh my god no that's
what we used to do i mean that's what i
do when i
i'm like i i i start with the emotion
then i start with
the package like how am i packaging this
then i start with the headline
then the preview image and then i work
backwards from there right um and i
always try
to find like i'll find something that
catches my attention just one fact or
one line so for example
um i was just doing research on
yesterday do you know um what recaptcha
is you know when like um
up for something you're signing up for
something that says spot right nowadays
they say like
spot click the thing or type in the uh
the
whatever picture is a sign click it yeah
it'll be like you know where are the
traffic lights click all squares with
traffic
lights and by the way this is a good
example i saw this meme
that was that recaptcha with the traffic
lights and in one of the squares just
the tiniest corner of the traffic light
is in it
and it shows the guy like suit like
sweating like crazy like oh [__]
should i include that or should i not
include that and that's one of those
where it's like me too
dude i i i almost feel that way i'm
always confused by this thing
that's supposed to so i always feel that
way meme
now here i can take it another way do
you want to know when i looked it up on
wikipedia you want to hear a fun
fact do you know why they do it this way
is because
people like google um i might be
butchering this just a little bit but
the
idea is the same people like google are
paying recaptcha
to translate stuff so for example
somehow picking out that sign or saying
where the headlights are that actually
helps google and google is paying you
money
because it's paying a little bit so the
original captcha was done by this guy he
was a professor at duke and carnegie
mellon and
capture originally was letters remember
it was always these kind of script
like kind of hard to read letters but
you could read it and that was basically
taking
they had scanned a bunch of book pages
but who's going to conv
the computer was not good enough at
trent getting all the book pages
to translate over to text in the
computer because some of the book pages
were a little
rounded or wrinkled or kind of fuzzy and
so
the computer couldn't do it but a human
eye could easily do it so they basically
outsource the work and solve two
problems with one stone
on the website side they just want to
make sure you're not a bot who's signing
up for their service
like a scammer who's going to spam
everybody but then
they did good in the world also because
that project
ended up transcribing like millions and
millions of books i think all the books
that they had
scanned eventually and then captcha two
is about a recaptcha
i believe is about image classification
so for self-driving cars we need to know
is is this a bus or what is this and so
i think that's where the original idea
was uh classifying images let humans do
it
while they signed up and the inventor of
recaptcha the second one his name is
luis von on
i think that's how you pronounce it he
did both and that guy started duolingo
and when he started duolingo he started
it for two reasons one he i guess he
just cared about
helping you learn language but two when
you are
learning the language you're actually
translating stuff that a third party
service is paying for you to translate
so this is crazy so what a genius the
exact
emotion that you just had of this guy's
crazy that is the mo
emotion wow this guy's actually i am
trying to evoke by sharing that
so i can tell that story in probably
five tweets and i bet
it will like virality is pretty
impossible to predict
but i can bet that there's like a three
out of ten chance that it's going to
that has legs i could say this has all
the uh this checks is all the box to get
popular i can't i ca
anyone who says that they're going to be
able to predict it they're wrong like
shawn's thing just reached five million
people he was like this is not going to
work
um the other part the other part you had
there that was good
is that you took a thing that we've all
seen that's a relatable oh yeah i've
filled one of those in and you
so you took a very familiar thing but i
told you the uncommon truth around it
um which i think is like really cool
like there's one yesterday i saw
uh you know tom cruise's name is not tom
cruise his real name
no what is it it's tom uh tom
cruise something it's like his middle
name is cruz and his last name is like
some
uh like very looking up it's some like i
don't know random ass like name
and he changed it to tom cruise which
sounds like a total movie star name
makes total sense that he did it
and um so yeah his real name is thomas
cruz
mapother the fourth or some i don't even
know how yeah i can't even pronounce
that
mappather yeah tom mappather versus tom
cruise
and so you take something really
familiar we all know tom cruise right
boom here's the uncommon did you know
and then it's like oh sweet like
wow you know and that one doesn't have
as much shock factor so it won't go
super viral but it'll get a lot of likes
but you know the closer you can get to
that
the surprise gap between what i thought
i knew and what's real
uh the more shares people will get yeah
i think if anyone cares about this stuff
i like the book made to stick and i like
the book contagious by jonah berger
contagious made to stick is how to say
something so people remember
and contagious is a great book by this
wharton professor on how to make things
get popular
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back